Nintendo has a successful franchise in
almost every genre for gaming but not
since Metroid Prime is it committed to
the shooter genre with as much gusto as
it is the splatoon the creatively
nonviolent shooter coming to Wii U this
may intono isn't scared of small
experiments introducing lightweight
games and new characters on occasion but
it's banking big on splatoon success in
hopes it will blossom into yet another
flagship Nintendo series by taking a
wholly wholesome approach to shooter
design splatoon already stands out as
something new and different bucking the
need for direct comparisons to bloody
behemoths such as Call of Duty and
Battlefield there are no headshots or
kill counts here in multiplayer modes
the goal is to cover the map in your
team's color using guns that are loaded
with ink rather than bullets because you
an inkling are a human squid hybrid
naturally the Inklings duel species
status means they can walk on two feet
but also swim through puddles of ink an
ability that's incredibly useful and
unlike any maneuver seen in other
shooters while swimming through the
opposing teams ink slows you down and
makes you an obvious target your own ink
is the perfect hiding place as enemies
can't see you if you don't move while in
squid form given that Inklings move
faster through ink than on their feet
you can also take advantage of this
ability to reposition yourself on the
map dodge enemy ink and get to high
ground where your modest jump ability
otherwise wouldn't allow the standard
turf war competitive matches are a blast
in splatoon and while it takes a bit to
get over the shoot-to-kill mentality for
most shooters it does sink in eventually
and that transitional moment is when
splatoon's greatness finally clicks
killing is a means to an end rather than
the end goal cover an entire area in
paint and you feel as good as you would
if you were taking out an opponent
something through inked across the map
and using it to pop in and out of cover
provides depth and strategy beyond what
many shooters offer which rarely extends
beyond weapon choice in positioning
players can also earn currency during
matches and use it to purchase new
clothing from splatoon humorous and
charming hub world which often comes
with stat boosts enjoying these
mechanics and the moments that result
from exploring their potential says
splatoon apart from other shooters but
it's missing something that every
competitive shooter must have if it's
going to be taken seriously voice chat
in Tendo for whatever reason has stated
there will not be voice chats with tune
rather than strategize by direct
communication Nintendo suggests that
players use the bird's-eye view of the
map on the gamepad to determine their
strategy but that's honestly a poor
replacement for the real deal
Nintendo has been pitching splatoon as a
competitive game first and foremost but
there is a single
player adventure inside that's fun on
its own offering a unique set of
equipment challenges and most
importantly level designs here you
actually are fighting to kill basically
taking out the octarians your
octopus-like adversaries you explore
original single-player only maps that
include squid and ink based platforming
mechanics and elements that are actually
reminiscent of mario galaxy of all
things this is a great way to hone your
skills before jumping into ranked
multiplayer matches but you'll actually
have plenty of time to practice for
those anyhow because they're only going
to be available post-launch
once a certain number of players reach
level 10 in the standard multiplayer
mode then Nintendo will set that feature
life splatoon has come a long way since
e3 where it was presented as more of a
vertical slice or a concept rather than
a complete vision now splatoon has an
established world and story a
single-player mode that feels distinct
from multiplayer matches and other
features including gear and ranked
matches that might learn fans of other
competitive shooters the lack of voice
chat is definitely concerning but still
I had a really fun time playing as a
squid trying to sneak around a map and
cover enemy territory with ink that I
actually wasn't too concerned for what
my team was doing really we were all
doing the same thing and I was more
concerned about where I could paint
rather than where my opponents were
splatoon splashes onto the Wii U in just
a couple of months and with it one of
Nintendo's biggest bets in a long time
its success both as a project and as a
multiplayer shooter but rely on a large
active player base it's not something
Nintendo's content it with in the past
and if anything it'll be interesting to
see how Nintendo handles all the new
challenges that splatoon represents
you